[Music]
The Rock's new baby his latest movie
Baywatch
it was a glitzy star-studded premiere on
the beach into Wayne's backyard of Miami
and all the stars had their families in
tow
[Music]
I mean everybody came this is what
happens when you have a premiere in your
hometown Dwayne's
immediate family included mom Atta and
daughter Simone Kelly Rohrback brought
her proud papa
it's got to be amazing watching your
child my god
no with Alexandra Daddario was her
look-alike sister look at the I put all
the girls in the family
I literally text my friends every day
like pictures of the posters that you're
in oh my god your sister I'm so excited
my parents and my aunt and uncle are
here just taking all this in a general
my mom chose to go to Istanbul for my
cousin's engagement so I brought her
sister instead to make her jealous on
Mother's Day also in on the beach party
they watch icons David Hasselhoff and
Pamela Anderson both of whom have cameos
in the movie does your life go into
slow-mo like that's gonna follow me
around that's a little bit of my
trademark yes I had to do a a scene with
a rock and the first thing I did was get
kid in the gym for six weeks he's like a
man and a half you know you might have a
few fam I think so it's pretty cool um
I'm stoked we've gotten accustomed to
watching these stars in their red and
blue bathing suits well for the premiere
they cleaned up nice just look that way
for a sec enjoy Vegas water was sweet
and feminine and pink we're in Miami so
it's Baywatch it's fun Zac Efron's kiss
my lips II he's happy about it in the
movie LLL finish kiss me kissing
everybody
[Music]
you